[Music]
Hey folks. Um, my name is Alex Volov.
I'm an AI evangelist with Weights and
Biases. I'm Benjamin Eckle. I am
co-founder CTO of DIPso. We're creators
of MCP.Run.
All right. And we're here to talk to you
about MCP observability.
Hey Ben, I want to ask you a question.
Somebody who worked at Data Dog before
and somebody who runs multiple MCP
servers and uh clients on production. Uh
something that happened advice that
happened something in my agent uh in
production the other day. Okay. Uh yeah,
I mean we've been running MCP clients
and servers in production since the
beginning. Uh yeah, but wait, aren't you
like working at an observability
company, Weights and Biases? And don't
you work on like what's it called?
Weave. Yep, that's true. I I work about
weave and but since I started adding
some powers to my agent via MCP all that
observability that I'm used to from just
having my own code run end to end has
gone a little bit dark. Gotcha. So this
is what we're here to talk to you guys
about. U the rise of MCP is creating an
observability blind spot. As AI agents
become more uh prevalent, the problem
can compound with more and more tools
via MCPS. The less they the developers
can know about the endto-end happenings
within their agent. Yeah. Um, yeah. So,
on MCP Run, we're running both clients
and servers. And because it's a new
ecosystem, we've had to like cobble
together a lot of our own ways to do
observability. And I've been looking
around. It seems like everyone is sort
of doing this in isolation. They're sort
of solving the same problems. Um, so,
you know, we wanted to bring the
community together on this issue. And
so, today we're going to talk about the
state of observability in the MCP
ecosystem.
Yep. So, why do we care about this? And
why do we think that you guys should
care about this? So if you don't have
the ability to quickly understand why
things went wrong on production, where
they went wrong and how, your ability to
quickly respond is greatly diminished.
And we care deeply about we both build
tools that need MCP observability. And
we support MCP and we both care deeply
about developer experience as well.
Yeah, it's it's really important to me
because enterprise engineering teams
don't ship something to production
unless they know for sure that they're
going to be able to identify security
and reliability problems before their
customers do. Um, and that's why they
invest a ton of money in observability
platforms. And uh, so if you're going to
ship MCP to these production
environments, you must seamlessly
integrate with these observability
platforms. Yep. So, because we care
deeply about uh developer experience at
W&B Weave, uh I'm happy to announce here
on stage that we've supports MCP. Yay.
As long as you're a developer of both
the client and the server, all you need
to do is set this MCP trace list
operation environment variable on your
client and server. And uh we'll show you
the the list tool calls and we'll show
you the the duration of your MCP calls.
This works currently with our Python
based clients. And this is how it looks
super quick. With the red arrows, you
can see the client traces, for example.
And with the blue arrows, you can see
we're pointing to the calculate BMI tool
and and the other tool. And that's it.
Observability solves, right? Let's get
off the stage. We're done. Wait a
second. So, uh what about this like
calculate BMI tool? This uh MCP server.
Why can't I see into that? Um you Yeah,
we're working on this.
Uh yeah, also this seems like this is
specific to Weave, right? Um is there
not like a vendor neutral way to do this
that's standardized? Yeah, that's right.
Uh this is a bespoke integration that we
built into weave into our SDKs in
Python. And while working on this, while
our developers have been building this
like u integration within our MCP
tooling, I was advocating internally and
externally that we should align with the
open nature of MCP as a concept and
created observable. Maybe some of you
have seen this. This is a manifesto to
drive a conversation that this is a
problem that needs solving and uh
between observability providers uh such
as us and other folks that's been on
stage before and going to be on the evol
tomorrow uh to do observability in a
vendor neutral and standardized way. And
so while working on observable tools I
realized I I did some search realized
that a vendor neutral scalable way to
add observability exists uh and there
could be a great way to marry the two
open protocols to work together. Yeah,
exactly. Uh fortunately MCP powered
agents are really just another
distributed system and we've been doing
that for decades. So open telemetry is
just the way that's that we've like
settled on doing that. Um we're going to
talk about OTL a little bit. If you're
not uh familiar with it, we need to
learn about a few primitives first. So
the main primitive that we need to learn
about is the trace. So a trace is kind
of like an atomic operation in your
system. It's made up of a treel like
structure of steps that we call spans.
And a span represents the duration and
some arbitrary metadata for each step.
And what this step is exactly is
completely up to you to define. It can
be as high level as like an HTTP
request. It can be as low level as a
tiny little function call. Um here's an
example of like a checkout experience,
an API for a checkout. The size and
position of each of these spans
correspond to how long it took and where
it sits in the call graph respectively.
And just from this data, you can tell a
lot about a system and how to observe
it.
Um the other primitive you need to be
aware of is syncs. So a sync is kind of
like a centralized database where all
your telemetry goes, but often they come
in the form of this like whole platform
with like a UI and dashboards and
alerting and monitoring and all those
things. So there's a lot of logos here,
Ben. Uh basically a sync is an open
standard way for folks like collectors
to like receive those spans. As long as
the developer instrumented their
application code in a certain standard
spec way, everybody can just receive
those in in the same unified way. Right.
Exactly. Yeah. It's if you squint, it's
just kind of like a bunch of databases
that all support the same schema and
wired protocol. You could switch them
out and in fact they don't have to
change much of their code or even change
the code at all. It could be just
config. Right. Right. Uh by the way
observability tools like W&B weave and
some friends Simon from Lockfire here
before and some other friends all have
switched to support otel as well. Open
telemetry is becoming like this global
standard.
Great. Uh yeah, another great thing
about having a centralized sync uh is
the last concept distributed tracing. So
going back to our checkout endpoint, if
the uh fraud service sends its span to
the same sync, then we can stitch back
the together the traces and show the
whole context. So maybe you're kind of
seeing where the MCP server stuff comes
in here. Yeah. So, hey Ben, if it's
possible via the integration to the open
protocol, um what if I want to use MCP
servers that other people host like
GitHub, like Stripe, like other folks?
Yeah, it's a good question. So, um with
MCP enabled agents or really just any
distributed system, there are kind of
two scenarios. There's when the client
and server are in different domains and
then there's when they're in the same
domain. And by domain here, I don't
necessarily mean the literal definition.
I mean like the administration
administrative domain of control, right?
like do like do you own this MCP server?
Do you own this MCP client or is it a
third party thing? So your GitHub stripe
example is like a great example of like
the different domain scenario. So um
this is a trace of an agent that is
executing the prompt read and summarize
the top article on hacker news. So it's
going to reach out to this like remote
fetch server to read hacker news, but it
appears to us in the trace as a single
service span because it's it runs
outside of our domain of control. So it
appears to black box to us.
Um but suppose we do own the server like
maybe it's running in a different data
center than the client. Um how do we get
actually the whole context? Uh it's
pretty simple. So with distributed
tracing and context propagation, we can
have the remote fetch server send its
spans to the same sync as the client and
the sync will just stitch together the
missing uh parts of the trace back for
us. So in this graphic you can see that
we can now break into that fetch server
and we can see what it's doing. It's
making some HTTP request that's taking
roughly 350 milliseconds and then it's
doing a little uh crunching to to create
some markdown.
Okay, so that that is great in theory
and we went through this. We could have
a whole hour talking about hotel. Not
that we got an hour. Uh but how do we
can actually marry those two protocols
together? Right. Uh is there a standard
way? Did the MCP spec folk deploy a way
for us for observability? Um not quite.
It was it was uh pretty tricky to get to
get working. um it does work today but
uh it required a little bit more work
than it should have. So in order to do
this we need to as I said propagate the
trace context from the client to the
server. So here's a TypeScript example
and when we call a tool in the client um
we're going to extract our current span
and we're going to uh pass it along to
the server. And we achieve this by
basically just shuttling the data
through the protocol's meta payload.
And uh now that we're inside the server,
uh this would be like in the fetch
server, we can pull that trace context
out, inherit it as our current span, and
then when we send our spans off to the
sync, uh it it's as if it came from that
parent span, and they the sync can
stitch it back together. Then this is
awesome. So you basically used an
undocumented kind of property of the
sending the payload together with the
payload between clients and servers um
to pass along the data that hotel needs
to connect those things together, right?
Yeah, sort of. I just kind of had to
abuse the lower level interface reserved
for the protocol, but a higher level way
should be provided through tooling. And
that's something we should talk about a
little bit later in the talk. Yep.
That's all. Oh, yeah. So, by the way,
this is uh this is not just um a
screenshot. This is a working demo. So,
um it's a lot more code than what I
showed in the slide. So, if you want to
actually go see how this works and adapt
this for your needs, uh go check out
this GitHub link. And I think actually
you did that to to get it to work with
weave, right? Yeah. So now that we know
how to pass context after you you you
showed me the way, uh let's see how
amazing the solution actually is in
practice. While Weave MCP, the thing I
showed you guys before was a bespoke
solution baked into our Python SDK for
Weave. The huge benefit of MCP generally
not only observability related is that
servers and clients don't have to run on
the same environment or share the same
code or be from the same programming
language. So while we were working on
the Python SDK, you built an agent in
Typescript and so because Wave WB weave
supports hotel open telemetry and it's
an open protocol uh your TypeScript
agent it took me a few minutes to by
without changing much code to just send
those traces into weave from a
TypeScript agent and not necessarily
from a Python edge. So here uh here you
could see in the green the the client
traces are in the green and then the
server traces actually show what happens
within those calls uh
on kind of the the server side as well.
Yeah, that's really cool. So how did how
did you actually get the traces into
weave? So this is very very simple way
simpler than before. Uh we just define
W&B weave as the OTLP endpoint standard
that you kind of like showed me around.
Uh and then folks can send their traces
into 1b.ai I/O hotel and all you need to
do in addition to this is authorize. So
add authorization headers and specify
which project you want to go into. Cool.
Yep. So while we talk to you about
thoseability, while I was working on
this, I had a magic moment happening
with MCP. I wanted to share this with
everybody and I love you as well. MCP
story. Yeah. So um
I used quadopus 4 that just came out to
weify your agent that you built and to
add this uh MCP observability and W&B
weave is going to get a little meta.
Stay with us. Uh also has an MCP server.
Okay. What what does it do? So we have
an MCP server that lets your agents or
or chats etc talk to your traces and see
the data and summarize the data for you.
Okay. So we have this MCP. it's been
configured in my windsurf uh and and CL
code uh OPUS 4 uh was able to use this
MCP server to kind of work through it.
So here you see an example. Um the agent
basically started working on your code
and then decided okay I'm going to run
the code and then said okay I'm going to
go and actually see if the traces showed
up at at W&BWeave. Then it noticed that
they showed up but they showed up
incorrectly. So some input or output a
specific parameter that it needed to do.
It didn't know how to do it wasn't part
of the documentation. And so uh the next
moment just absolutely blew my mind.
this OPUS 4 discovered that our MCP
server exposes a support bot. So
essentially another agent uh decided to
write a query for it, received the the
right information after a while and
acted upon this information, learned how
to fix the thing that it needed to fix,
fixed it and then went back to notice
whether or not the fix was correct. So
my um my coding agent talked to another
agent via support vcb that it discovered
on its own. I didn't even know that this
ability exists to work on your coding
agent in in things. Things got a little
bit meta and my head was like
absolutely. I was sitting like this
while all this happened. Didn't touch
the keyboard once.
That's awesome. Yeah, it's pretty meta.
Uh yeah, before we go, I also wanted to
have uh take a moment to have an
announcement. So um MCP run will also be
exporting telemetry to hotel compatible
syncs. Um so as I mentioned before, we
run both servers and clients. Uh so for
servers we have this concept called
profiles and these allow you to like
slice and dice multiple MCP servers into
one single virtual server and on on uh
we also have the an MCP client called
task and this is like a single prompt
agent that could be triggered via URL or
a schedule and it also just sort of
marries with the idea of profiles. Um,
but yeah, soon you'll be able to get
Otel out of both of these and hopefully,
you know, we'll uh connect up to weights
and biases and have a little party.
Yeah, you can send those to Wave
Straighter from MCP.Run.
Okay, so uh to recap, um observability
is here at in MCP today, but it's not
evenly distributed. Uh should get you
most of the way there, but the community
needs to come together uh create
creating tooling and conventions to make
it smoother. um you shouldn't need to be
an expert in observability to like get
this stuff working.
So how do you get involved? Well AI
engineers just start thinking about
observability via MCP tooling and
whether or not you're getting uh
observability to the end to end of of
your execution chain. Um for tool
builders and platform providers we
should join and work on higher level
SDKs. So uh arises as open inference for
example is a great start but all of us
should help with instrumentation for our
clients who use bespoke SDKs to work on
conventions also together. Ben can you
explain semantic conventions super
quick? Yeah sure. So as we learned
earlier um spans they carry userdefined
attributes right so if they're
userdefined how does the sync know that
a span is actually say an HTTP request
with a 200 status code or how does it
know that it's an MCP tool call that has
an error. Um that's where semantic
conventions come in. Um and you can be a
part of defining what the conventions
are for agents that all observability
platforms agree on. And if you're
interested in this, I would suggest
going to check out the uh Genai semantic
conventions effort by the hotel team.
And um yeah, lastly, for platform
builders such as MCP Run, um you know,
go add hotel support, help review RFC's.
And finally, yeah, just come like talk
to us about ideas because we're just
everything's just kind of coming
together. Everything's so new and fresh
and we don't really know exactly what to
do. There's an additional track here at
at uh AI engineer. this called the
hallway track and I've learned more
about the stuff that we were talking
about uh out there by actually talking
to people who implement this than I
learned while preparing uh before the
talk. It's quite incredible. So, um
yeah, sure. Um yeah, so again, I'm Ben.
Uh my call to action here just be go
check out MCP Run. You can get a free
account, try it out. Uh yeah, that's it.
And I'm Alex. Uh uh check out W&BWeave
MCPOP to learn how to trace MCP with
hotel. Uh I'm also I did the observable
tools initiative. I would love for you
to check out the manifesto to see if
this resonates with you to join forces
to talk about observability and uh we
yeah please visit us at the booth. We
have some very interesting surprises for
you. We have a robotic dog right here uh
that's observable. I also run the
Thursday I podcast. I want to send Swix
a huge huge shout out for uh having uh
giving me the support to show up here
and give if you guys are interested in
AI news, we're going to record an
episode tomorrow. That's it. Thank you
so much.
[Music]